[Applause]
i could make a list of
of a few who are like beyond politics
remember ben is here budo
no no no really the prime minister yeah
are we on
the prime minister
yeah okay come on
all right are we all right
okay all right we got it
okay here we are we're talking about
politics hot
uh for panel if you had to make a bet on
who will win the gop nomination in 2024
ron or don and that's who it's going to
be the trump or desantis uh who would
you bet it would be well there's a broad
open question don don
ron
i'm i'm leaning more toward ron
ronald mcdonald
no i think i think i i think santa says
a shot yeah oh he's got more than a shot
yeah i mean he's i think he won the
straw poll in new hampshire and
he he feels a little christian to me
like he's peaking right now but he's not
actually gonna like
land the plane oh no
well he's not christy-esque
he is very christy-ass no christy's
twice the man he is
okay uh the u.s economy added over half
a million jobs in july is that proof
that biden was somewhat writing claiming
that the u.s is not in a recession
yes
there is a lot of suspense there
i think isn't it dangerous to do weekly
statistics and try to figure out
well i mean reasons like this i mean
haven't we learned that that things go
yearly also like yearly three yearly i
mean it's like well do you think no like
i mean that's not a bad thing but
there's not a bad sign but i wouldn't
say yeah
it's a moot point question because
people don't it's it's how they feel and
how their actual it's like trump's
finances like how i feel about in the
moment is how much i'm worth right
well
he always feels very well about himself
but i mean there's an actual definition
of recession when gdp
declines for two quarters but no one
knows that or gives a [ __ ] about it
that's actually a name it's more of a
press definition because there's there's
another definition that it's based on
the national
uh what is it bureau of economic
research yeah
you've already lost everybody
rate is relatively insignificant
compared to how people actually feel i
will agree with you and the employment
polymer is 3.5
that's as low as it ever goes now it
also could be people are in shitty jobs
they don't like
i mean that people
well i don't i don't think she works for
you i need to work here i don't think
audience member here is a shitty job i
think
it's one of the better jobs you
can being uh a recent study shows that
loneliness and isolation raises risk of
heart attacks and strokes by 30 percent
wow you know they should get those
people on obesity right now and figure
it out
a double whammy
what are your thoughts on this dave
being that you wrote your latest develop
during a time of worldwide social
isolation absolutely i mean you know
statistically they can they can point to
things like that and i suppose it's true
i mean statistically but it also
intuitively makes sense you know when
your heart hurts right that's stress and
that's your heart i mean it's not your
physical heart but it does seem to be
some kind of correlation well i mean one
of my big issues with western medicine
why i don't want them ever to tell me
what to do with my body is because i
could name a thousand things but right
off the top they pay no attention and
give no credence to the mind-body
connection
and if you can't
you can't read it on a chart
if you can't quantify it and that's not
i i think in 100 years we will be
looking back at the way they do things
now and just the way we look back a
hundred years ago do you really think in
20 years they'll be going like yeah 2022
that's when we pretty much had it all
figured out
[Laughter]
no we look back a hundred years ago i
can't believe they're doing it i i can i
can name things they're doing right now
that i know as a layman that are going
to look bad
right i mean 80 percent of coveted
people in the hospital got antibiotics
which don't work on viruses no there'll
be sometimes other reasons why you would
give but just antibiotics the way they
give them out like skittles
i mean i'm glad we have such a thing but
they're making it so they're not going
to work anymore because we over
prescribed them i mean that's just one
of
dozens of things anyway don't get me
started on that or do
after the
thank you
oh
yeah
thank you for uh you know amongst the
swag that you give out thank you for the
uh the uh box of ivermectin
well
he's written about that
that's a that's a good example i i
assume that you're being snarky liberal
about that
i've erected the snarky okay
well because that's but good example
like if you only watched msnbc what you
heard was this was horse medicine the
rooms are taking horse medicine
okay it's not just horse medicine okay
all right but i mean that's a good
example of how people are in their
bubbles and they only read and see one
thing oh these rubes you know who's a
rube anyone who's wearing a mask outside
those that's a [ __ ] way you know
i see 22 year olds wearing a mask
outside
what [ __ ] morons
[Applause]
i don't think it was the i don't think
it was the rubes i don't think it was
making fun of the rooms i think it was
actually wow
casting aspersions on the on the
republican on the right elite who who
have an anti-scientific
uh agenda to
to propose you know so it's not again
who's
again it's a very
tricky thing to throw on anti-scientific
yes
take it back
when there's so much this is live bill i
only got no i know i'm just saying but
there's been a lot of bad science on
both sides but that's how science look
bill science works badly science works
by making mistakes right how does it
work okay but we should we should yes it
does
until it does it okay so therefore
therefore don't say fauci says if you
don't believe in me you don't believe in
the science well that's there's no the
yeah okay yeah well i think you've been
wrong about a lot of things yeah i think
patrick's time has come and gone no
well also i mean fauci 81 he had didn't
have trouble with covid biden 79 didn't
have trouble with it the queen's 150.
can we stop
with the forever we also sometimes work
backwards from like the politics of it
like when donald trump came out and said
that he took hydroxychloroquine
for everybody that was like
automatically the drug doesn't work
whereas right the drug it's not a drug's
fault that's true exactly
there's no republican or democratic
drugs yeah exactly i've heard mectin has
been given to millions of people i don't
want it something might cure right or
maybe there is an agenda to throw a lot
of
stuff out there to see what sticks from
one side rather than
the more monolithic scientific side on
the other side
i agree with that but again it's not the
drug's fault right yeah yeah right so
like you still have to like i began this
by thanking him for the ivormectin in my
dressing room
in a mocking way
after the us announced killing al-qaeda
leader amanzawa hiri some people are
asking if this truly makes america safer
what are your thoughts
um well i have can i lead i have some
please here please do you know the idea
that because it's 20 years later that we
should somehow let this guy go and
retire in florida
is absolutely
[ __ ] ridiculous to me
my view
my view on this is that we should find
and hunt down
every single person who helped plan and
execute the 9 11 attack even if it takes
us to the gates of heaven i know where
they are
i know they're golfing with trump trump
in new jersey
it was the saudi arabians
that's who did it and you know what's
amazing to me about this is and and
no one should ever compare anything to
the holocaust and i'm certainly not
going to do that here
but
you know what we can learn from the nazi
hunters we can learn from the mossad
because you know what those
[ __ ] are still hunting down
nazis today no yeah they are yes they
are they would have to be a hundred
exactly they are finding the hundred
year old ones and if you're talking
about the active nazis in the past not
the ones in the press yeah exactly yes
yeah yeah yeah but if you commit these
atrocities
you can't you're not let off the hook i
don't care if it's 20 years later if
it's 30 years later oh oh there's gonna
be some retribution from al qaeda like
what they're just sitting on their hands
and like oh we're all good with america
now no so
my only uh pushback on that i did a
story on uh that touched on al zawahiri
a couple of years ago in the drone
program
we've been trying to kill this guy for a
long time and he's been reported dead at
least twice
before
there's a human rights group in britain
called reprieve that reported that
we we bombed a school and there were 79
kids and 20 oh sorry 76 kids and 29
adults who were killed uh trying to get
alzheimer's trying to get out
the the there were two big attacks in
2006 there were some others my point is
we're going to do that that's a fact
that's a fact that we killed all those
people and we know it was trying to you
can yeah you can go
because i never heard that yeah there
were there were two big attacks and and
there was a town called har and another
one it called in called shingo the point
is we're going to make more al zoa hiris
that way and that's what i worry about
we apparently have improved the
technology because we got the flying
ginsu knife
and
also
i must say i i find it so interesting
the hypocrisy of the al qaeda leaders
because they said
bin laden was living in a cave remember
he wasn't in a cave he wanted to be in a
badabad he had a nice house and i was
second we pulled out of afghanistan also
here he moves back into kabul they want
the nightlife they want the good
restaurants they don't want to live in
the cave out in the [ __ ] mountains
they want a place in town they want to
be in the city yeah but the line was all
like
a battle bag right
i don't mean to be too serious here but
one other thing about this was um a lot
of biden's critics said that when we
pulled out of afghanistan that we were
going to let the terrorists just run
wild there and this sort of blunts that
criticism
wait
who said
a lot of biden's critics but the
terrorists are running wild the taliban
are completely back in charge and they
reneged on everything they ever said
they were going to do women are back to
being third class citizens and they're
letting the terrorists move back into
their piano tear in downtown kabul what
are you talking about running wild is
the head of al qaeda
zawahiri
okay so i think that matters
well there's always
okay well he was and we got him but they
let him back in the taliban
were not good partners not honest
negotiating partners so look i will i'm
all for though i think biden did the
right thing by pulling out of
afghanistan you think that yeah yeah
okay and and it was a it was a tough
decision yeah it was right and he did he
stick the landing no
it's so disappointing why something that
consequential couldn't have been done
with more efficiency it just makes me
worried years ago
yeah
what or 10 years ago 10 years ago but
the fact that he finally did it they had
time to plan it and when they when they
finally pulled it off it's like they
only thought of two days before
and it just it makes me worry about
everything in this country because this
country just really can't do anything
efficiently and i thought the military
was the last
line of defense all right
i've kept you long enough thank you very
much you're rehired man
you